make sure you stay have the tardigrade
feels cute but they'll eat you and don't
get sucked into a time vortex we won't
be able to save you look forward in time
to view alternate futures to see all the
possible outcomes of the coming conflict
how many did you see
14 million 605 how many we win
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we have some
brand-new stuff from the people that
made ant-man the wasp about stuff that
didn't quite make it into the movie that
helps with that post-credit scene and
dr. Strange's plan for shadow time
travel during Avengers 4 and the idea
that Doctor Strange saw what was going
to happen during ant-man the wasp was
Scott laying down in the quantum realm
there's new giveaway stuff that I'll
explain at the end of the video if
you're new be sure to subscribe to get
everything so you don't miss any of the
videos the really cool thing that we
just learned is is that during the early
pre-production phase when they were
beating out the story for ant-man and
the wasp they were trying to think of
things for her to do with Scott Lang
like they did at the beginning of the
movie where she was practicing being a
superhero one of the things that didn't
quite make it into the movie but they
intended to do was teach her how to ride
ants and built her her own tiny little
kid ant-man costume so at one point
there was like an 11 12 year old Cassie
Lang being full-blown stature in an
ant-man costume with Pym particles
flying a tiny size we all heard Kevin
Feige talk about the Young Avengers
movie that they're planning on doing in
the future in how we have crazy
time-travel alternate universe theories
going on in Avengers 4 there was the
casting notice for an older version of
Cassie Lang that would have been say
1617 implying a bit of a time jump
during Avengers 4 at some point and then
Janet Van Dyne at the very end in that
post-credit scene says oh and by the way
watch out for time vortices they're all
over the place you know what that means
is is they wouldn't have included that
line of dialogue if it wasn't going to
be critical to the plot otherwise they
would have stopped her short at that
joke about him being eaten by
tardigrades just watch out for them
they're dangerous so if you ever
wondered about movies like this they
don't throw out lines of technical
jargon like that in a serious way
without it actually meaning something to
the plot or future plots the way these
movies are tied together in most of the
post-credits scenes foreshadow what's
happening in future movies this is
obviously foreshadowing Avengers 4
because of the snap moment at the end
now that we've seen both of these movies
too we can also say the Doctor Strange
because time
Travel was such a big concept that they
introduced with the way that Thanos used
the gauntlet to reverse the damage to
vision so that he could take the mind
gem dr. Strange's one in 14 million plan
that would allow them to ultimately
defeat Thanos playing the long snap game
this is a long game remember he knew
that they would all have to die for this
to happen but that also means that he
saw the plot of Avengers 4 in what Toni
would end up doing why Toni was so
important that's why he didn't let him
die that's what that whole scene about
them arguing on the black order ship was
about I will not hesitate to let you in
the kid die if it comes down to you or
the stone doctor do you concur
all right started we go to him
you have to understand if it comes to
saving you or the kid or the time stone
I will not hesitate to let either of you
die I can't because the universe depends
on it so he was ready to let Ironman die
until he saw that one and 14 million
plan that Ironman was critical for so he
knew that he needed to survive and he
very calmly and quickly gave up the time
stone like Ironman didn't know what was
going on because he didn't explain what
the plan was that he foresaw just the
Doctor Strange knew what was going on
and knew that he didn't need to put up a
fight at that point like this is all
part of the plan so just give it up just
make it look like we're bowing in
submission so it looks like Thanos is
winning and because Stannis was in such
a hurry to assemble all the gems in form
the gauntlet he didn't bother to use the
time stone the same way that dr. strange
did because if he had taken a couple
minutes he could have actually used the
time to see into his own future and see
what was going to happen during these
future movies the reason why I think
that they would want to include a future
version of Cassie Lang and show stature
future Avengers or Young Avengers
however you want to think about them
because she'd still be sixteen years old
same age as spider-man during spider-man
homecoming is that they want to give you
a little tease of things that could
potentially come in the future because
Kevin Feige did say that they legit
talked about doing a young Avengers
movie at some point and they want to
give you different versions of the
heroes just so that you know that
they're gonna be cycling the roster a
little bit in the future so they'll get
you used to the idea but also pay off
some of these things they've been
setting up the idea that Cassie wants to
be a hero just like her dad the same way
that a young version of spider-man here
in Iron Man 2 was inspired by Iron Man
during the events of that film and
eventually wanted to become one of the
Avengers until he got the spider bite
and learned that that might actually be
possible at some point so the story of
Avengers 4 has to let the original
Avengers sort of ride off into the
sunset semi-retire so that they can come
back and cameo every once in a while but
make room for new heroes but also
introduce you to really crazy concepts
like time travel in the multiverse so
that they can do even crazier stories
and it makes it easier to incorporate
things like mutants and the Fantastic
Four and all these Fox characters
without having to completely retcon
everything within the unit
so hopefully that explains what's going
on with Cassie lang with this new
concept art a lot of the time-travel
truthers have also been pointing to the
older looking version of Tony Stark why
is his hair all white looking here and
it's much browner here I know
everybody's been talking about that
scene with him in Wakanda in sharees lab
I'll do a separate video about that
because that gets into some of the new
pairings and Avengers 4 so like you have
your teams during infinity war it's
gonna be the same thing during Avengers
4 they're gonna have some really
interesting new pairings like Iron Man
and Sheree in the film the two
supposedly smartest people on the planet
trying to figure this problem out how do
they save the universe so even if Scott
does go into the future and sees a
future version of his daughter as a
teenager a full-blown stature young
Avenger I don't think it's gonna be a
longer scene than what we saw when iron
man went to the sanctum feels like a
longer scene that it actually is before
they spill into that big black order
fight so you do have to remember that
even though they have all these crazy
things are gonna introduce the movie is
gonna move pretty quickly the Russos
wouldn't confirm how much of it they
edited right now they only said that
it's very unfinished like it's not a
complete film meaning that they haven't
finished their rough cut yet and they're
still scenes from the reshoots that they
have to add to that so it's a long ways
away from it having any kind of assembly
cut or then being able to put together a
legit trailer which is why I don't think
they were gonna see any footage from it
till much much later this year like the
story that we are telling with each
character's really compelling and rich
so yeah we do have to there were early
drafts and script they were insane and
it probably had 100 speaking parts
different approaches to style in terms
of execution one even had finished
narrating most of the movie so I don't
think that we're gonna see any kind of
teaser for that till much much later
this year we'll learn the title before
we get an actual teaser like they'll
just tell you what the title is we'll
all freak out then a little while after
that we'll get some footage but like I
said there's a new round of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a Marvel related comment on
the video click here for brand new venom
footage and click here to learn what's
going on with Thor 4 in guardians of the
galaxy 3 thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
tonight
[Music]